blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman ladies and gentlemen republicans
have suffered a completely
humiliating defeat last night losing
really badly their attempt to recall
democratic california governor gavin
newsom and to replace him with there was
really only one person who might have
replaced newsome if the vote had gone
yes on recall rather than no
and that is the absolutely radical
republican named larry elder now we're
going to go through some different
aspects of this story here but the big
narrative is
mostly right wingers in california
despite claims that the left also isn't
happy with gavin newsom some democrats
not happy with gavin newsom but by and
large
mostly the right wing of california many
of them pro-trump decided to try to
remove the governor gavin newsom
the top alternative
was a republican named larry elder who
agrees with donald trump on 99 of
everything the only disagreement i was
able to find
between larry elder and donald trump was
that larry elder didn't like
the chinese tariffs that donald tr uh
that donald trump put in place but
beyond that this was a guy who was not
only pro-trump but in some cases even
beyond trump saying he would end every
mask requirement if he were to become
governor he would end every vaccine
requirement if he were to become
governor he has a long history of
deranged political statements um
misogynistic statements homophobic
statements racist statements even
and he got absolutely crushed
in terms of the first question the
recalls are a two-part question the
first question is should governor newsom
be recalled
70 percent reporting this morning
mail-in ballots left to be counted but
64 percent of voters said no
new some should not be recalled
uh basically a two-to-one loss for those
seeking to remove gavin newsom i mean
just a resounding and humiliating defeat
now had the recall gone yes
remove gavin newsom then it would have
gone to the second question and it would
have been larry elder who became the
governor of california elder got 47
percent of the question to vote
followed by friend of the show kevin
paffrath who ran as a democrat called
into the live stream we did last night
nice guy uh although my position all
along has been just vote no do not
recall gavin newsom so it was going to
be larry elder if newsom didn't stay now
this is a major bullet dodged and a
major humiliation for republicans and
this is also to some degree
a referendum on trumpism this entire
take them out attitude replace them with
a pro-trump republican
this is to some degree a signal about
the power of trumpism which may be we
don't we don't know yet
the power of trumpism may be diminishing
we won't really know until november of
2022 but it is a good sign that this
movement failed and failed so miserably
at attempting to replace the sitting
democratic governor with a trumpian
lunatic republican in larry elder now
what exactly happened here how did this
all end up the way it ended up well
remember
that early on and we have the polling a
trajectory for this race up on the
screen now for people who are watching
early on there was a long period of time
about three full weeks in august where
the polling was almost completely tied
and we were worried about that it was it
was it wasn't too close it was tied
between keep and remove gavin newsom but
two different things were going on first
in a recall
the people wanting the recall
are often more engaged for a period of
time since everybody else is just living
their lives they're not looking to be
involved in a recall this isn't a
scheduled election
and so as more and more californians
learned about the recall and its
paramount importance
you saw more and more say no i'm
actually going to get involved i'm a
likely voter now and i want to keep
gavin newsom
secondly the most important issue for
recall voters was covid and so as larry
elder explained he said i would get rid
of every guideline around kovid as delta
grew in august larry elder's cartoonish
position on kovid only helped gavin
newsom even more and ultimately it went
very much in gavin newsom's favor let's
look at a couple of different clips here
is fox news
eventually calling it i think this was
after 1am um dave wasserman called this
at like 11 15
eastern time i think this was like
around 1am
um this was fox news calling it last
night now steve stand by because the
associated press has now just called it
you see the numbers on the bottom of
your screen see the check mark there
67.3 32
yes that means that gavin newsom will
not be recalled the associated press has
now called it you've got 58 of the vote
in there it is and actually that may
have been earlier and then larry elder
eventually came out and spoke this may
have been around 1am eastern elder
finally saying
we may have lost the battle but we have
not lost the war let's be gracious let's
be gracious in defeat
[Applause]
and by the way
we may have lost
the
battle but we are going to win the war
so at the end of the day
this was just a bad idea
and it was an expenditure of political
capital for doing nothing other than
being resoundingly defeated and spending
more than 250 million dollars to do this
this optional recall election which
wasn't even close there was no shot at
removing
gavin newsom
250 million dollars the very same people
complaining about
profligate government spending
acted to spend 250 million dollars on an
election that ended up humiliating them
and also was completely unnecessary now
there are some right-wingers who are
turning around and saying
this failed because california's full of
stupid liberals
just get out of california and ben
shapiro basically tweeted as much last
night saying quote the failure of the
california recall is a reminder to
republicans still in the state
the decline is now inexorable
get out while the getting is good and
move to a purple or red state your life
will radically improve well that's fine
and let's see if people do it we have
freedom of movement in the united states
between states the california exodus
that they've been claiming is going on
for a long time hasn't actually been
going on and they also for being free
marketeers they seem to miss the fact
that the reason in part that things are
expensive in california is because
there's a lot of demand to live in
california in those parts much of
california is actually dirt cheap if you
get away from the popular areas on the
coast and some inland cities there's a
lot of california that is really really
cheap why is it so expensive to live in
santa barbara a tiny city of 90 000
people versus just to pick a place with
a similar population parma ohio
maybe you've never heard of parma ohio
maybe you have
the reason santa barbara is more
expensive is because more people want to
live in santa barbara because it's nicer
with better schools access to better
airports better infrastructure and
california ranks fifth in healthcare
compared to ohio at 37th this is the
market
because more people want to live in
santa barbara than in parma
that drives prices up
because there's a limited supply of
housing and space and jobs in santa
barbara if the politics of california
disgust people and they move out demand
will go down and it'll get cheaper and
wherever those people go
demand will go up and it will get more
expensive if all the people wanting to
live in santa barbara
go and live in parma ohio parma ohio
will become more expensive i don't know
if healthcare will get any better maybe
over time with additional tax revenue
who knows but this is sort of like the
way the market works and these people
seem to very much not understand it so a
disaster disaster for republicans in
california let's hope it's a sign of
things to come in the 2022 midterms but
house races in florida are very
different than a recall election in a
full state election like california so
let's not get ahead of ourselves okay
one thing i do want to go back to
is the
crazy decision that larry elder made
before his humiliating defeat in
california to start claiming voter fraud
before we even had the election results
he saw the writing on the wall and this
is also a very trumpian approach now a
very trumpian tactic say it's rigged if
i didn't win it must have been rigged
because a true election a fair election
an honest election would have resulted
in me winning this is the approach uh
and i want to remind people we should
not forget that this is what they did
this is an article from yesterday larry
elder prepares for california recall
loss with lawyers and a voter fraud
website
with less than a week to go until the
california recall some republicans are
falsely claiming votes are rigged in
favor of democrats and suggesting
without evidence that govern governor
gavin newsom can only win with
fraudulent votes the claims are
unsubstantiated and echo similar false
messages promoted by republicans last
year following the election of president
joe biden we wondered if this would be
the new tactic applied to any election
they lose and so far the answer is yes
larry elder the top polling republican
is already planning to challenge the
recall results if newsom survives elder
told reporters in los angeles on
wednesday he believes they're very there
might very well be shenanigans but he
expects to win anyway
elder said his campaign nevertheless is
ready to file lawsuits and encourage
people to report any issues we have a
voter integrity board all set up most of
these are lawyers we're going to file
lawsuits in a timely fashion a link on
elder's campaign website labeled as
report election incident took whoa sorry
about that
took users
to a forum to report incidents of voter
fraud and sign a petition to investigate
the result of the recall understand that
they had a petition to investigate the
results
two days before there were any results
now after we reported this yesterday and
so did the sacramento bee and others
they changed the site okay they removed
the petition to do an investigation of
the results apparently realizing it
looks really bad to do that before there
are actually any results now we also
have clips
reminding us of their strategy here is
an interview that uh jacob soberoff from
msnbc did with larry elder on monday
multiple times asking larry elder will
you commit to accepting the results and
larry elder was slippery to say the
least larry elder the leading republican
candidate would not commit to accepting
the results of the election
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow i think we all ought
to be looking at election integrity no
matter whether you're a democrat an
independent or republican let's all make
sure that the election is a fair
election so this all work together no
matter what the results are to make sure
that the results are valid and
legitimate and everybody who voted
should have voted let's all do that
together is that a commitment to accept
the results of the election tomorrow
let's all do that together let's all
work together uh on both sides of the
aisle to make sure that the election is
a fair election now to his credit
larry elder did concede last night or
early this morning
and based on what we know right now this
might change in the next couple of hours
based on what we know right now
it doesn't actually seem like he's going
to be pushing
uh anything and and part of the reason
why is when you lose so overwhelmingly
so humiliatingly
what is even the plausible mathematical
case for this not that there really was
one with trump and biden either but this
is just a different this is a different
animal altogether uh trump was also
getting ahead of this uh by saying in
advance this was uh last week that it is
it seems they already rigged it in
california got the recall election
coming up in less than a week uh it's
actually happening as we speak the polls
appear to show newsome look safer at
this point larry elder is the man uh
that could take it from him what do you
think happens in california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're very
good the one thing they're good at is
rigging elections so i predict it's a
rigged election let's see how it turns
out so this is the same playbook i mean
it's not just larry elder using the same
playbook as trump
even trump was involved in using the
same playbook and applying it to the
california gubernatorial recall so in
terms of larry elder actually uh getting
a petition going for voter fraud
investigation before the election maybe
they accidentally published the page too
early or maybe not and then once they
realized this looks really disastrous
we're going to pull the page down but it
is increasingly clear
that this is going to be a tactic for
republicans for some period of time it
will be really interesting to see and
you know there's so much up in the air
about the november 22
midterms if they get crushed in november
of 22 republicans that is they will have
trouble pulling the it was all rigged
thing because it's just going to be like
come on again guys you're just losing
and you're losing badly
if it's close or republicans narrowly
take the house
but not by that much they will start
arguing hey you know what we took the
house by three we really should have
taken it by 40 but they rigged so many
elections so i believe this tactic is
going to rear its ugly head again and
when you can't win on policy
you try to go with ad hominems and then
claim that they stole the election for
you let me know your thoughts how long
is this going to be the republican
tactic you can find me on twitter at
dpakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
so in the middle of the entire
california gubernatorial recall which we
covered yesterday and already earlier
today on the show an insane bombshell
story dropped on the basis of a
forthcoming book from journalists bob
woodward and robert costa
where there are a number of disturbing
and dystopian claims and stories that
are made and told
and we have to start with what may be
the craziest one which is that general
mark milley was so afraid that in the
aftermath of losing to joe biden donald
trump would launch nuclear weapons
that millie had to assure china
trump's not completely out of control
and millie even having an emergency
meeting with other top military brass to
try to figure out a way of if trump
tried to do this can we actually stop
him from doing it and we'll talk about
whether this would even really be
possible okay so let's um start with a
cnn article
reporting on the content of the book
listen to this
two days after the january 6 attack on
the capital
trump's top military advisor joint
chiefs chairman general mark milley
single-handedly took secret action to
limit trump from potentially ordering a
dangerous military strike or launching
nukes
according to peril a new book by
legendary journalist bob woodward and
veteran washington post reporter robert
costa woodward and costa right that
millie deeply shaken by the assault of
january 6
was certain that trump had gone into a
serious mental decline in the aftermath
of the election with trump now all but
manic
screaming at officials and constructing
his own alternate reality about endless
election conspiracies if five percent of
this is accurate trump was completely
losing his mind behind the scenes
exactly as we believed he was doing
millie worried that trump could go rogue
the author's right
you never know what a president's
trigger point is milly told the syria
syria senior staff
in response millie took an extraordinary
action and called a secret meeting in
his pentagon office on january 8
to review the process for military
action including launching nuclear
weapons
speaking to senior military officials in
charge of the national military command
center the pentagon's war room millie
instructed them not to take orders from
anyone unless he was involved
now is this even
does this break chain of command we're
going to talk about that in a second
no matter what you were told you do the
procedure you do the process and i'm
part of the procedure milly told the
officers according to the book he then
went around the room looked each officer
in the eye and asked them to verbally
confirm they understood got it milly
asked according to the book yes sir
millie considered it an oath
the author's right
peril is based on more than 200
interviews with first-hand participants
and witnesses and paints a chilling
picture of trump's final days in office
the book woodward's third on the trump
presidency recounts behind the scene
moments of trump's unhinged and
explosive actions yelling at senior
advisers and aides as he desperately
sought to cling to power it includes
reporting of the events leading up to
the january 6 riot trump's reaction and
newly revealed details about trump's
january 5 oval office showdown with mike
pence
woodward and costa obtained documents
calendars diaries emails meeting notes
transcripts and other records
um
[Music]
one other part of this and then we'll
we'll get into some some discussion
millisphere was based on his own
observations of trump's erratic behavior
his concern was magnified by the events
of january 6 and the extraordinary risk
the situation posed to u.s national
security milly had already had two back
channel phone calls with china's top
general who was on high alert over the
chaos in the u.s
the uh then millie received a blunt
phone call from nancy pelosi woodward
and costa obtained a transcript of the
call during which millie tried to
reassure pelosi the nukes were safe
pelosi pushed pushed back what i'm
saying to you is that if they couldn't
even stop him from an assault on the
capital who even knows what else he may
do and is there anybody in charge at the
white house who was doing anything but
kissing his fat butt over all of this
pelosi continued you know he's crazy
he's been crazy for a long time
according to woodward in costa millie
responded madam speaker i agree with you
on everything
and then what maybe is the key
uh revelation here
is millie becoming so afraid
of trump's actions millie ended up back
channeling with uh chinese officials and
saying it's going to be okay we've got
this under control so we are quite
literally talking here about a president
going nuclear an actual lunatic as
president and it's the same people who
thought that this trump was the guy that
it made sense to make president who now
don't want the vaccines so think about
that for a second now there's a real
question here and a bunch of people
emailed me about this thing
is millie in a sense overstepping
authority here uh later we're going to
get to clips of trump calling what
millie did treason i think that that's
outrageous but did millie overstep
authority here i think the the most sort
of balanced and sober reaction to this
is that ultimately
millie would not have authority
over trump when it comes to
nukes
and preventing him from launching them
okay
at the end of the day
whatever system milly puts in place uh
as a chairman of the joint chiefs
trump could fire milly
and then replace him with someone who
ultimately will allow trump to launch
nukes
now
what i think millie was trying to do
here
is given the limited amount of time
that trump would have to do this
remember the riots were on january 6th
milly's meeting was on january 8th trump
was leaving office on january 20th or
21st i don't remember inauguration day
at this point so you're talking about
under two weeks
my belief is millie knows that
ultimately
uh trump can fire him and put some yes
person in
who will let trump launch nukes
ultimately trump can get his launch
order through
but millie knowing trump probably
realizes trump has this sort of uh
limited attention span
and eventually if it's too difficult to
get it done trump will look the other
way or his attention will go to some
other shiny object so obviously at the
end of the day
it comes down to you know the nuclear
silo officers to actually launch
missiles it is ultimately at the
discretion of the president but my
understanding is millie's idea here was
let's just make it difficult enough
so that trump would have to fire me and
maybe other people in order to get this
done and maybe that prevents it from
happening the real story here is
the mere fact that the chairman of the
joint chiefs was so afraid this would
happen
is an incredible historic story that
goes to the unhinged and erratic nature
of donald trump a little bit later on in
the show we're going to get to some of
the reaction from trump to the story
coming out
all right i briefly want to talk about
one other aspect of so-called vaccine
mandates i've said for a while i think
uh it should be required to fly in the
united states um airlines governed by
the federal department of transportation
it should be required to be vaccinated
to fly
um i say this less because of the spread
on airplanes but more because it seems
from the polling we have that being
vaccinated being a requirement to fly
would actually convince a lot of people
to go and get vaccinated and this is
becoming more and more of a topic over
the last few days
nbc news reports that dr anthony fauci
would support a vaccine mandate for air
travel now as you may know some airlines
are requiring vaccines for workers but
have not mandated mandated it for
passengers the nation's leading
infectious disease expert dr anthony
fauci said he would support a cove
vaccine mandate for traveling on
airplanes i would support that if you
want to get on a plane and travel with
other people that you should be
vaccinated he said in a clip of an
interview with the schemes podcast
the u.s travel association monday
responded to fauci's comment saying
science and studies show air travel is
safe as long as face masks are worn
u.s travel has long maintained there
should be no mandatory vaccination
requirements for domestic travel this
would have an unfair negative impact on
families with young children not yet
eligible well you can always exempt
young children that's not a good
argument let's listen to what dr fauci
said if we get the overwhelming
proportion of the population vaccinated
we will get to hurt immunity if we do it
in the next six months it will happen in
the next six months if we do it in the
next two months it'll happen in the next
two months i would support that if you
want to get on a plane and travel with
other people that you should be
vaccinating when you hear us say should
you mandate okay so now they're going on
to another topic i've got to tell you i
am 100
in favor of this and again it's not
because airplanes are the number one
point of spread
it's because so many people have said
a hundred bucks is not going to convince
me to get vaccinated uh even my employer
saying i've got to get vaccinated or
test weekly that's not going to get me
to get vaccinated but in a number of
polls now we've seen that as many as 41
percent of those not yet vaccinated say
if it became a requirement to get on an
airplane i would go and get vaccinated
that's why it is not about the spread on
planes but about what we can do to get
people vaccinated we also have data
about people want that uh forbes article
most americans now want vaccine mandates
for planes hotels and restaurants per
gallop
um in the four months between april and
august as the delta variant swept across
the u.s support for travel related
vaccine mandates ticked noticeably
upward
more than 6 in 10 americans now support
requiring proof of full vaccination
before getting on a plane up from 57
support for vaccine mandates for hotel
guests reached a majority status in
august notching up nine percent from
44-53
the largest shift on vaccine mandates
involves eating out between april and
august there was a 13 percent jump in
support for having to show proof of
vaccination status before dining in a
restaurant 53 percent of americans now
support it compared to only 40 percent
four months ago
and 58 now support a vaccine mandate for
going to large events like concerts and
festivals this is the
vaccine requirements to fly
popular among americans not a reason to
do something americans might want
something that's a bad idea but popular
among americans
and
admitted to
by the anti-vaxxers that if it was
required to get on a plane
they would go and get themselves
vaccinated many of them and supported by
dr fauci i would like to see this
it is now known it is being considered
by the biden administration
i hope that it will be enacted soon if
you disagree with me
let me know we'll have more coverage of
this story on the david pakman show
instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
okay let's now get to the reaction from
a whole bunch of different people
including donald trump himself to the
absolutely
revelations the claims being made in the
forthcoming book from bob woodward and
robert costa as we told you in an
earlier segment
the chairman of the joint chiefs general
mark milley was so worried that in the
aftermath of his loss to joe biden and
the january 6 riots
that donald trump was so
out of it
that he would actually maybe try to
launch nuclear weapons and we learned
about in the book we learn about the
things that mark millie did in order to
try to prevent this including having
some kind of fail-safe type conversation
with the top military brass phone call
with uh chyna uh phone call with nancy
pelosi etc well donald trump appeared on
newsmax yesterday on the show of
sean spicer his own former press
secretary
and
saying a lot of really crazy things
let's just jump right into it so first
of all if it is actually true which is
hard to believe uh that he would have
called
china and done these things and was
willing to advise them of an attack or
in advance of an attack that's treason
now it would only be advising them in
advance of an attack if this story is
true and trump was really thinking of
nuking china i mean understand now trump
in a moment will deny it but think about
what trump is saying trump is saying you
know if we're doing an operation a
military operation of some kind
including a bombing and you go and you
let the enemy know ahead of time that's
treason
but in order for that to be the case you
have to be saying that it's true which
now which trump now says is not true
anyway and i would think i've had so
many calls today saying that's treason
number one number two it's totally
ridiculous i never thought of it you
were there you were you knew what was
happening in the world if you never
thought of it then what millie did made
sense which was assure china
that you're not actually about to nuke
them so which is it i mean even the
explanation is completely incoherent you
have plenty of friends you never heard
the word china mentioned in a thing like
this you heard a lot of anger about
china on trade and we made a great trade
deal you heard a lot of anger in china
with the china virus the trade deal was
a disaster there was no deal it was
tariffs that were completely
counterproductive remember just to be
thorough
but
for them for him to say for him to say
that i would even think about attacking
china i think he's trying to just get
out of his incompetent withdrawal out of
afghanistan the worst the dumbest so
remember that was trump's withdrawal
plan first and foremost trump's
withdrawal plan
uh but if there was really no plan or
even worry that you were going to go
after china
then it's really no big deal for millie
to say guys we're not going to nuke you
we're not going to nuke you it's okay
don't worry so it's a it's a
flip-flopping trump's furious
for conflicting reasons both of which
can't possibly be true thing that
anybody seen probably the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to our country where they
they killed our soldiers
they we left with embarrassment
so now trump's on to afghanistan by the
way yes we left americans behind and we
left 85 billion dollars worth of the
best equipment in the world that i
bought
because i was the one that rebuilt our
military and then biden gave it that's a
lie as well away
for him to say that i was going to
attack china is the most ridiculous
thing i've ever heard and everybody so
again millie is not saying trump was
going to attack china millie was saying
we were worried he might
lash out and try to launch nukes
but we believed we had a plan to prevent
it and we assuaged the fears of china
it's like trump trump he's
misunderstanding the story three
different ways and responding to it in
three different ways that are conflicts
with each other does he know it no does
sean spicer know it or care probably not
he knows it and i have to tell you i
don't know if they have him on tape
saying this but i found woodward and i
found
his cohorts to be extremely dishonorable
people that's why i didn't do an
interview with him i think he's highly
overrated this guy is one of the most
overrated guys he's a sleaze but i did
not ever think of attacking china one
other thing i just read a report about a
week ago where they said donald trump
was the only president in decades that
didn't start a war okay so that
an often repeated phrase that out of
context and without any serious analysis
means very very little so
trump everybody's terrible the reporters
are sleazes the the general is a
lightweight note the constant ad
hominems and attacks here trump drops in
during the interview without evidence
that obama is actually probably
currently in charge not joe biden he's
the opposite he's worse than obama of
course obama is probably running the
government now anyway according to many
yeah so a former president saying it's
actually it's a different president the
president that's officially the
president's not really the person that's
in charge okay that's there's a former
president saying it um and then lastly
here here is donald trump with a sort of
completely delusional framing of the
perception of america's place in the
world
the people of our country respect us
they love our country and they want to
see our country succeed and our country
has gone really downhill in the last
eight months like nobody's ever seen
before now remember
the polling is
respect for america globally is up
basically everywhere russians liked
trump
there i don't remember there's like one
african country and then also maybe
turkey where trump had like okay
approval and respect around the world
everybody else was disgusted by trump
globally respect for the world is up
now that trump is gone it's the opposite
of what trump is telling you and you go
to these elections that are coming up in
22 and 24 we're not going to have a
country left the election was rigged and
we're not going to have a country left
so a final lie there as donald trump
signs off so trump
highly triggered by this report which in
all likelihood
is true at least in the spirit even if
not every single detail
um can be independently confirmed that
that's sort of my sense of it the book
is well cited and well researched and
we're going to continue to learn more
about it now let's go to some other
reactions from people
to the blockbuster claims from bob
woodward and robert costa including at
the top of the list that a chairman of
the joint chiefs general mark milley was
so afraid trump was so unhinged in
milly's eyes that millie was afraid
trump might nuke someone and started
putting in place all of these safeguards
let's go piece by piece this first
interview was stephen moore a former
economic adviser to trump appearing with
neil cavuto
and in responding to the revelations of
the book
moore again refuses to even say trump
lost the election like he's still on
that this guy is pathetic and no push
back from neil cavuto
i think that those questions really need
to be asked about joe biden in his
mental capacity right now but no i never
saw that from donald trump i do think in
a few days after the election he had a
hard time coming to grips with the
results yeah that that's the
understatement of the century and i
think he's obviously still uh doesn't
believe that he lost but
no i don't i do not believe he was ever
in a state of incapacitation where the
country was ever in danger
do you believe he lost the election
i believe there's a lot i believe we'll
never know the real answer to that i do
believe there was a lot of voter fraud
but i also believed you would you
couldn't unscramble that egg and once
those votes were counted there was no
that way they were going to be
overturned and we'll see whether you
know look i do believe there's a high
likelihood right now that donald trump
will run for president in 20.
do you understand what he did there he
is so they are
first of all
this is such a simple question did
donald trump win or lose the election
and the answer is he lost
and you can not like joe biden and you
can say listen neil
the people spoke and it wasn't even that
close joe biden won and that's it they
still can't even acknowledge that
they may never acknowledge it they're
not seemingly getting over this
but more actually goes a step further
and says
it may be an unknowable thing we may
never know who actually won the election
which is like an extra little wrinkle to
the thing which is i'm i'm not saying
trump definitely won but i'm certainly
not saying trump lost
but i'm adding on to it we won't know
which is exactly how these people will
cling to the belief that maybe trump won
when you start hearing people say it's
unknowable it's a you are basically
saying it's a matter of opinion it's a
we we don't know we will never know it's
a scrambled egg you can't unscramble an
egg
um
and and so it justifies people having
the opinion that trump actually won when
it is an empirically knowable thing okay
here's a couple here's rand paul
commenting on the mark milley report but
if it is true absolutely immediately
needs to be removed we we have elections
we can't have generals overturning
elections that we have always criticized
in authoritarian regimes where the
military takes over this is very very
dangerous and uh if this happened milly
needs to be immediately removed
of his command
we can't have generals overturning
elections we can't have authoritarian
reversals of our elections
that's exactly what donald trump wanted
in terms of mike pence
and may even have been thinking about
how the military could be used to that
end but rand paul says oh we can't have
millie controlling election and then
lastly here's another just off-the-wall
reaction to this here's laura ingram
in responding to the revelations about
trump and nukes and mark milley
downplaying the riots of january 6th
again democrats and trump haters have
clung to the events of january 6 with a
white knuckle death grip
they claim a riot that the capitol
police should have been prepared for was
actually an insurrection the shortest in
world history by the way it was an
attempted insurrection laura please but
today we learned the truth there was
indeed an insurrection being planned
around that time in washington but it
took place at the pentagon and its chief
architect was general mark milley can
you imagine
the insurrection was mark milly's and of
course
that's not true
but they don't know where to go with
this stuff you've got two reactions
basically uh taking place to these
revelations about trump and the nukes in
china
one side is it's all lies
all the interviews the transcripts the
records the fact checking they're it's
just they're all all all lies and you
can't believe any of it the other side
is it's all true
and it's treason by mark milly well guys
you're going to have to pick one which
is it are they all lies or are they real
but it's treason by mark milley figure
it out because i'm starting to have a
hard time keeping up let's take a quick
break we'll be back after this with so
much more
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show so there's
a lot of liars in politics and there's a
lot of terrible people in politics and
sometimes they're the same people the
terrible people also happen to be really
big liars and i believe that florida
republican governor ron desantis is one
of those bad people who is also a liar
yesterday i played a clip for you which
we are going to look at again today
in which ron desantis held some big
press conference at which he announced
that if a business tries to require
sorry if if a florida state government
agency tries to require a vaccination of
an employee they will be fined five
thousand dollars at this very event
some guy came to the lectern
stood behind the seal of the florida
governor
and said the vaccine changes your rna
now i'm gonna play it for you if you're
watching you will notice
uh desantis definitely looks like he
heard it he seems to get a little bit of
a not super comfortable look on his face
when it's said because it doesn't look
great to have such unhinged unscientific
anti-vax statements said when you're
trying to make the case we're not
anti-vaxx we're just pro-freedom well
the vaccine changes your mrna is pretty
bad or your rna i think he said um
so it does seem as though desantis heard
it all right let's take a look here's a
reminder of the clip right the vaccine
changes your rna so for me that's a
problem
so i i'm here with you folks um
we don't want to have the the vaccine
it's it's about our freedom and liberty
so my interpretation
is that desantis clearly seems to be
reacting to the wacky nonsense that that
guy is saying about the vaccine changes
your rna
there's a new report now a lot of people
said rightly why didn't why didn't uh he
go up to the lectern and immediately say
that's not true that would have been the
responsible thing to do
um there is now a report that ron
desantis says
he just didn't hear it
he just didn't hear it guys desantis
denies hearing false comment that covet
vaccine alters rna
governor ron desantis on tuesday denied
hearing a false comment that the covet
19 vaccine changes human rna even though
he was standing next to the person when
he made it
honestly i don't even remember him
saying that so it's not anything i've
said
i think the data is clear you're much
less likely to be hospitalized or die
if you are vaccinated the guy who said
it is darris friend a 22 year old member
of the gainesville workforce and a
plaintiff in a lawsuit against the
city's vaccine mandate he spoke at the
event
um at which the governor said he would
find local government leaders who
require workers to get vaccinated the
vaccine changes your rna
and ron desantis is saying
i just didn't hear it guys i'm gonna
play it once more for you i get that the
audio component of this is less telling
but if you're watching the video
desantis is listening to the guy
he's two feet away from the guy he seems
to look a little sick to his stomach
when he hears this but the claim is i
didn't hear it
the vaccine changes your rna
so for me that's a problem
so i'm here with you folks
we don't want to have the the vaccine
it's it's about our freedom and liberty
it's not about the vaccine
so i don't believe for a second that ron
desantis didn't hear it we wondered
yesterday
why is this guy not contradicting what
is being said by these people and
obviously the most simple explanation is
not he didn't hear it he was two feet
away listening and visually reacted to
it the most simple explanation is this
is an event at which the idea is to just
make it overwhelmingly clear vaccine
mandates are bad and it would not be
conducive to that to interrupt and say
actually that's not true but the
mandates are still bad and blah blah
blah blah blah so taking the i just
didn't hear it approach
ron desantis one of the absolute worst
governors in the country right now
do you believe he didn't hear it i don't
believe it for a second my friends
all right i was not initially going to
talk about this story which is why i'm
sort of a day late on it although much
of what i'm going to talk about actually
happened in the last 12 to 16 hours
there is a um i think it's appropriate
to say a pop singer
named nicki minaj
who has been posting some sort of
strange things to twitter lately and
other social media related to the
pandemic and related to science
um nicki minaj has close to 200 million
that's not that's not an error close to
200 million followers across all social
media platforms
and the day before yesterday she tweeted
a very strange anecdote about the
coronavirus vaccine where nicki minaj
said quote
my cousin in trinidad
won't get the vaccine
because his friend got it
and became impotent
his testicles became swollen
his friend was weeks away from getting
married
now the girl called off the wedding
so just pray on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision not
bullied presumably meaning not bullied
into getting the vaccine now this is a
really weird anecdote for a few
different reasons first of all there's
nothing in the scientific literature
that suggests testicular swelling can be
a cause can be caused by the vaccine um
it's also sort of strange because
why would swollen testicles mean the
wedding is off
is it because you're getting medical
treatment or like the does the the
fiance just not want to be married to a
guy whose testicles swelled
or is it that actually the swollen
testicles were the result of maybe an
std
obtained from uh infidelity i don't know
that that was sort of my tongue-in-cheek
suggestion i got involved in this and
responded actually and said quote
this is a very technical response i said
is it maybe possible the swollen apple
bags
were an std from cheating and that's why
the wedding was called off now some of
the amateur
doctors in my audience told me david
there are no stds that cause testicular
swelling that's not true
i researched it in fact both chlamydia
and gonorrhea can cause something called
orchitis which is a swelling of the
testicle so anyway
like we don't we don't do anecdotal
stuff we go by we go by science and
uh
peer review and randomized controlled
trials and you know one person whose
testicles swell in trinidad doesn't
really tell us too much about what we
need to know this story has exploded so
first of all
yesterday on cnn jake tapper actually
asks dr fauci about this specifically
take a listen to this
speaking of uh trusted messengers
and pop star nicki minaj tweeted
yesterday that she's not vaccinated
she's doing her own research and then
she shared an anecdote i found rather
unbelievable to be honest about alleged
side effects that her cousin's friend
supposedly experienced in trinidad i
wouldn't normally even ask you about
this but but nicki minaj has nearly 180
million followers on twitter and
instagram combined she's beloved by her
fans she's a huge talent obviously her
tweet was seized upon by vaccine
opponents as some sort of evidence i
want you to address
what she said because for anyone out
there who has any questions about this
dr fauci is there any evidence that the
pfizer the mederna or the j j vaccines
cause any reproductive issues in men or
women
the answer to that uh jake is a
resounding no
there's no evidence that it happens nor
is there any mechanistic reason to
imagine that it would happen
so the answer to your question is no
how can health authorities even attempt
to combat this kind of misinformation
coming from somebody who is a huge and
beloved international star like nicki
minaj
it's very difficult
the there is a lot of misinformation
mostly on social media
and the only way we know to counter miss
and disinformation
is to provide a lot of correct
information all right so that might have
been it right nicki minaj tweets about
the swollen testicles
the wedding is off
it makes one day of rounds and it's sort
of like there's no evidence for this
there's no medical reason this is this
is one person
uh just because something happened
after something else doesn't mean that
it was caused by that thing
uh okay fine
but then tucker carlson jumps in
and tucker carlson is very interested in
this story very very interested in this
story and the clips from tucker carlson
are indistinguishable from parody first
tucker offering a clarification
um it is not nicki minaj's cousin's
testicles that were swollen it is nicki
minaj's cousin's friend's testicles
things about that tweet last night we
read it we put the graphic on the screen
and we suggested that nicki minaj's
cousin is the one with the swollen
testicles in trinidad right and we were
wrong and we want to admit it we
henceforth correct the record
nicki minaj's cousin's testicles are not
swollen as far as we know he's fine it's
nicki minaj's cousin's friend's
testicles who are swollen yeah okay so
that's already crazy but then this is
really the wacky part
tucker wants to interview
nicki minaj's cousin's friend
about his swollen testicles
orchitis now is going to be a subject
on the tucker carlson program and not
only does tucker want to interview the
guy
tucker is willing to fly to trinidad
this is a clip the this may be
the clip of tucker carlson that would be
you know in an archive to be to be
reviewed a thousand years from now by
society
listen to this
we haven't been able to figure out
whether this show is broadcast in
trinidad
but if nicki minaj's cousin's friend is
watching or his former fiance who's
watching we want to hear your story
we'll come to port of spain to see you
let us know
one case of swollen testicles in
trinidad
and tucker will take his entire
production team down there and do an
entire show about your swollen testicles
guys we're in real trouble here aren't
we i mean that this now is going be i
don't even know
how to characterize
and quantify and qualify
the insanity that is spreading like a
virus in this country
um
one thing after another after another it
is truly truly stunning but tucker
he's on the story he's ready to go
interview
nicki minaj's
cousin's friend
about
his allegedly swollen testicles which
came
chronologically
after supposedly receiving
some vaccine but we don't really know
much else about it
we're screwed guys right i mean this is
this is not
humanity is not pointing in the right
direction at this point in time i think
we can say we have a voicemail number
which you can call any time of day
that number is 2192 david p
today i have sort of a it's almost like
a political f mary kill it's kind of a
weird voicemail let's listen to it
hello
imagine that um let's say you're on a
stranded island okay and
you have some people with you now you
can choose from five people
and the five people are yep kyle
kolinsky okay nando villa
john idarola
anna casparian
jankuger and you can only choose three
of those people to be with you on the
island wow
okay listen i i get that this is a joke
but here's my thought if my uh so one of
these people i don't know who it is
nando vela i think he said i don't know
who that is so
listen there's no right way to do this
right but i'm going to first just stick
with the people i know
that leaves us kyle
john
from tyt anna from tyt and jenk
now i don't uh
i i i
i've never met john in person
uh kyle
anna and jenk are people i've known for
a long time
and this is not a criticism of john
john's a great guy as far as i know from
our social media interactions but if i
was given these choices
on the desert island
i'm saving kyle
i'm saving anna
and i'm saving jenk these are not uh
reflections of any
political agreement or disagreement on
any issue in particular i don't even
know anything about that
it's just those are the three i've met
so those are the three i'm saving on the
desert island all right guys but that
would be a grim situation that would be
a grim situation regardless all right
we've got a great bonus show for you
today consumer prices are actually
uh rose less than expected in august
this seemingly is a good sign if you
were one of the inflation spiral
fearmongers
but they're coming up they're moving the
goalposts as they often do
also you might remember this program
cops when i was growing up this program
cops was very very popular
and the program has been pulled
because of a combination of
seeming to sometimes kind of glorify
police violence
and
being
seemingly
problematic in other ways in terms of
different things anyway
the program is apparently being brought
back by fox nation so we're going to
talk about that on the bonus show today
um and also apple's co-founder has
announced the private space company to
clean up the space debris
that is increasingly in our skies above
us
um very interesting new project steve
wozniak we are going to talk about all
three of those stories and more on
today's bonus show don't miss it really
guys don't miss it sign up at
joinpacman.com
and we will see you then otherwise we
will be back with a new show tomorrow
but my preference would be i would love
to see you on the bonus check
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman